and welcome to punch-drunk sports where
winners win joining us in studio today
is a friend of shell friend of life
friend of love friend of Brody's friend
of all of ours everyone's favorite
guests on the show
Bryan Sports ban red band what's up guys
[Applause]
back from his very successful European
crushed or in which he got to do kill
Tony all over the UK welcome bud thanks
guys under these very somber sad times
in LA comedy community Oh whole commie I
think New York is sad to see attles got
be sad Arizona Arizona's got be sad as I
Arizona State's baseball team did a
moment of silence for him oh really I
was awesome that was really cool do we
have that can we see that anyway I'm
sure yeah I saw it on Twitter so Johnny
could I pull it up I thought someone you
know that'd be great but all the time I
never knew apparently he pitched
baseball hadn't never knew all this time
you know the picture he should have
pitched he should have talked about it
why would there it is to it oh I'm glad
there's a [ __ ] ad for it
okay we're sorry for the ad people
tennis was pretty weak that day college
baseball Brody's mom probably some
[ __ ] chick with eight year old but no
arms no probably some awesome black
stripper in Arizona because they got
next-level out there and they loved to
sing you see the Cubs manager he was
also on mlb.com oh and then they and
then they were that makes me sad dude
festival sports he had so many festivals
he really was that was his last week
yeah let's do more festivals yeah well
he's doing one he's doing a big festival
in the sky probably killing yeah he's
probably bitching about spots now
he's like why is there no the sky go up
all the time
no he's learning all the street names in
it glory Boulevard I've been there
hey Jason where you gonna be I'll be at
the Comedy Store this weekend and that's
all I really got I'm kind of laying low
right now okay zoom and zoom aah boom
comedy spot stop John Madden
we talks about how funny he was but just
a nice nice man great heart kind heart
and really before I was interrupted go
on I'm at the comedy spot in Scottsdale
Friday and Saturday next week House of
comedy Minnesota Mall of America
Thursday I'm doing a Dolph Ziggler and
Sarah Tiana show at the Mall of America
so come on after that you see a lot of
malls dog lot of mall festival of malls
first of all malls hey my good friend
where will you be
we got a bunch of kill Tony's we just
did a new Philadelphia dates and we're
gonna have three kill Tony's there they
keep on selling out so that's good thing
Philadelphia break a show me yeah it's
pretty cool we also have a show next
Monday at the Comedy Store with Tom
Segura and a bunch of other people all
right I was at the Comedy Store
yesterday watching kill Tony and the
psalm the Brody soundboard red band was
on it yeah right sure it was great I I
found this old phone it took me forever
to find his old self I remember when he
had that app away all of his things you
used to have it nice to have a
soundboard app and he can't get it
anymore and so I was like trying to get
it and I was like you know what I have
an old phone city was that your ringtone
to one of them as well yeah and so I
found this old cell phone that had that
that soundboard so I spent all day just
taking all the sounds from it and
putting it in my soundboard so I've now
have like a hundred Brody saying so last
night I'm kill Tony
it sounded like Brody was there no we're
just enjoy it you're like what so
tonight is comedy chaos I believe it's
either close solo or sold out so if you
can get a ticket go grab that Thursday
night at the dojo of comedy it's the
dojo of comedy night we got Whitney
Cummings Michael Rapaport Ryan sick his
brother a couple other fun no names
name names I think it's uh I think zoom
and zoom ox gonna be theirs Wow way to
bury the lead okay he's gonna be there
the following week is the inaugural
Brody Stevens Festival it's the enjoy it
Brody Stephens festival friendship that
is the first of what will be a yearly
thing my goal is to produce this thing
every year once a year and I've already
talked to other clubs about doing it all
on the same day so we all we have
multiple shows going to help waste
mental awareness and a suicide
prevention we're also gonna help out his
mom I don't know how his mom is doing
but anything she needs from all this
whether it's every dollar or some of the
dollars will all go to her I hope
somebody's checked in on her you know
and everything like yeah I think our
tomorrow
Adam egit steve simone and steve
randolph are meeting with the family at
Brody's apartment to clean up and to
discuss what the next step is I promise
you this not one of these dollars will
ever go into my bank account I've
already informed The Comedy Store keep
the check and do with it as the family
wants and if that includes helping the
mother out I would prefer that and so
that's where we're at I will be with
Eddie Bravo a tinfoil hat in Washington
DC I believe the 8th is at Spokane we
are a nine o'clock show and then the
following day we are in tacoma we're
doing a 420 430 show on that saturday
following and then ah that's not DC
that's in the state that's state thank
you dumb ass dumb dumb ass
a-hole checking out clothes I was
looking at the penalty box but then and
then I will be in Arizona on the 20 you
got it Arizona 28th we're at the house
of comedy again a tinfoil hat and then
just announced Tucson we're gonna be at
tool no 9 1 9 tool Eddie Bravo myself
Tucson you can get all those tickets
Sam Tripoli
yes holla yeah boy guess what I got a
text from Judd Apatow no way
get the [ __ ] out oh god oh my god what
what'd he say because you you you uh was
hilariously you did a great tweak to him
where is that sweet but the point is
there's a moratorium on this this this
difference in opinion again I've said
before I I have nothing but I have no
problems with him the person it's comedy
but that's put aside for this thing he's
doing a memorial for Brody Stevens at
Margo so they asked me where they should
donate the money that bother and brought
it really didn't care for him well I
don't that kickstarted yeah don't forget
about that Kickstarter yeah and what's
that go for me go from me it's uh it's
good to say I'll go to my go to my
Twitter you can go there and you could
find its donate I know it was almost up
to 15 grand I think yeah yesterday went
four hours is great and the be honest
with you would you say about [ __ ] yeah
so what did he say
basically like hey man we're running a
show I'd love to know where we cannot
donate the money that's really all this
oh he's kissing your ass now you know
puffing out his chest a little benefits
gonna be way better you know what that
sound means it's time for us to take off
a piece of clothing I'm starting out for
myself by the way you have the funniest
line what do you look like today
Jason Tebow that eyelid
what did I say that right I used to
write country music but it wasn't that
good Brian so tell us about Europe man
how was it it was cool we started off in
Ireland and we ate oysters in Ireland
and does that sound like a good idea no
I'm hey dude
what do we do over Ireland I love
wasters oh when I'm in a restaurant they
have oysters I usually try them out but
it was a bad idea I I slept walk here's
another thing that happen I I got really
wasted in Ireland and then I went back
to the hotel you do in Ireland yeah and
then the middle of the night I slept
walked to go to the bathroom and I went
right out my front door of my hotel room
only wearing boxers classic I pee in the
hallway perfect and then I tried to go
in I heard I thought I heard Tony in
like another room so I started banging
on this tour and then when I'm like
knocking on this door I suddenly wake up
I'm like wait what the [ __ ] am i doing
and then I looked down and I'm like I'm
not wearing clothes and I had no way to
get back in yeah Nate in the hallway and
I peed in the hallway the huge puddle in
front of my door so then I had to like
get in the elevator 7:00 in the morning
so there's like all these people like
like leaving the hotel you just see this
hairy fat white guy with no clothes on
go dude like and I'm like hey I need my
I left my key inside the room and the
guys like oh yeah this happens all the
time
Thanks that sucked I've never done that
before this guy knows how to party so we
put in if you want finally go for me
what are you gonna go for me put him
believe it Brody Stephens Brody Stephens
believe it and all that stuff so it's up
to $13,000 in one day why does it say
sam tripley chase bank account below
that yeah I got lost [ __ ] people were
giving me a lot of [ __ ] on on Twitter
but it was very vague you know I know
there's been some really shady GoFundMe
they were trying to say I was in first
of all I didn't set this up I was added
as administrator by the two ladies who
set it up and I got told that there was
a bag what's the mental health thing am
I gonna you know and I'm like dude at
the time it was a $10,000 limit I go do
you think $10,000 is enough for me to
lose the respect of all my friends and
peers in the [ __ ] county community
it's
it's $10,000 yeah can you change it to
like if it gets to 15 yeah all right
just keep going we already did a patreon
for it but I wanted to ask Brian where
he was when he got the news and how he
heard it uh I was little Esther sent me
a message and goes what's up and I'm
like hey how you doing and then she's
like did you hear somebody I think
Howard Kramer is that his name he put it
and then I started searching everywhere
else and there was no other news about
it like on Facebook and I'm like I don't
think though if that's real like it like
that seems like a joke and then of
course I texted Brody and then and then
then I texted on Barris and dombarris
goes yeah I just talked to his manager
and so that's when I found out and yeah
that was that was rough that was I mean
this whole weekend has been really rough
hanging out The Comedy Store you know
it's just been you know yeah I did to
quit yeah until Friday which was brutal
Saturday it was even worse that's what
we all kept saying Saturday and worse
and then I've been back yeah they are
you know I know through the social media
that it's been like a bombardment of
everybody sharing their memories and
that's been really nice but I just feel
like he's been I haven't seen him in a
hundred years you know it's been five
days I feel like I haven't seen him in a
hundred years
oh there's so much content of Brody
though luckily you know like there's so
many videos that took us all our wives
to get through I mean I've sat and
watched like I've watched him the old
Rogen appearance where he would came out
as 10% gay that was one of the funniest
funniest things like I was gonna go she
ate and what percentage yeah we got up
to like 86 percent or something like
that if you if you want to laugh your
ass off on YouTube just type in Brody
ten percent gains somebody put together
like a 15 minute video and it's you had
a top one the top one and that that is
like one of the funniest videos I've
ever seen in my life
I was there I don't remember it being
that funny you know what pisses me off I
would talk with Brody about his TV show
enjoy it and he wanted comedy
to put it out you couldn't even buy it
but now he's dead it's daily put it out
for everybody I'm like he was fighting
for this when he was alive yeah that's
when I used to [ __ ] with lighting all
the time now it's all just brick
[Laughter]
pixelation in his mouth from a man I've
never ever wanted to do that why do you
keep saying 10% well Bryan keep saying
10% it's a running joke based in truth
based on these factors and experience
[Laughter]
was a statement that would really work
if everybody knew what you were saying
so what you're saying is a 10% game open
with it what does that mean does that
mean you're 10% gay I came out on my
podcast probably like six months ago you
came out 10% drink
- bridge who needs a beer and an answer
it's also based on when you were in the
fill of did you know Joe did you know
any of this part at this story I heard
rumors online since I love Brody like a
brother since we were brothers in the
art of stand-up comic comedy since we
are old school comedy store brethren
it's having fun having fun matters it
does and that's why you should tell us
about what happened in people without
too much away we do explain it in my
show leave us hanging you know I'll tell
you but I don't give it away because if
people see on the show you got a big
audience don't see it on the show again
okay trust me this is a puzzling case
we're gonna want to examine this from
everything they're gonna want to find
out I guarantee the the amount of people
that download that Icehouse Chronicles
we brought this up they're gonna go
through the roof what number Brian all
these different bars and the other they
have to get together young girls who sit
next to you for a coca-cola will dance
for you they'll sit by your side they
smell good if you really want to be with
them you can spend the money and it's
actually I want to say that
and then you go upstairs and then it's a
little different you're getting a little
like whoa that looks a little different
in there that the bone structure is
interesting but I see some other people
dancing and then there's one quad that
you go in it's like I guess the best one
up there and it's just they're having a
party it's fun the girls look like girls
like maybe summer guys I guess but it
was one of these [ __ ] bars and work
hanging out there having fun and though
you know they they they will touch you
they're very forward they will touch
your leg but they look like girls they
smell like girls look like girls
the treatments and you're sitting there
alone by yourself you're an ear in
Bangkok you're working on hangover to
touch it's normal to get aroused like
how he's telling himself
there's normal timezone from America no
comedians have gone down to Brazil or
Thailand there's old history of it so I
didn't really pursue it there but I
thought about it and then maybe I came
back on another night I go you know
people thought it was very bad no he
came back right well I was there for
like two weeks
I said maybe I came back oh you're
making the story confusing okay it gets
in this it gets into some hilarious [ __ ]
where he's talking about childhood how
like everyone like made fun of the way
he walked and he goes I think I became a
little Gabe I went to so many Brody
loopholes this weekend just going down
these YouTube radicals yeah yeah I've
been super Santos it's so funny is that
you know you talk about how like the
Arizona State baseball team had a moment
of silence and Joe Madden did that nice
thing for him and you don't know how how
much you
touch people and a friend of mine lives
in Finland and sent me a gonna post and
Forster yeah but send me an article in
the front page of the Finnish newspaper
in Finnish it says the star of the
hangover movies passes away I'm like you
[ __ ] you got that joking again
one more [ __ ] time right honestly
other side of the world in another
language hey you should ask Judd why he
cut out Brody Stephens from funny people
ah yeah let it let us at least see the
footage because it's not on the blu-ray
that text oh you got his phone number
that's one thing he always jokes about
you know being cut out of funny people
this is the moratorium on this ship I
don't know what the advertising budget
was for The Hangover film oh here it is
so he could look it up and we could show
it send it he's gonna send you the
finish finish story of Brody but the
budget was for The Hangover films but I
guarantee Brody did more advertising for
that film than anyone in the world yeah
for sure
just the plugs alone yeah I can't stage
Brody Stephens was my first podcast kiss
that squad at my house oh yeah yeah it
was in it was before I even had that in
my living room where we did not isha or
in the bedroom it was in my living room
and it was the our first time we had
benji on and it was the first time
meeting tony Hinchcliffe and it was
really weird and awkward for me because
he wanted Tony on the show really bad
and I'm like wait who's this guy Tony
hit no that's that's
Esther's ex-boyfriend that calls at 4:00
in the morning and you know and like
I've been like yell at him like stop oh
and my girlfriend when I was the first
episode brother yeah but you've been the
name it killed Tony
Eskimo brothers but but the first
episode was called Brody Stephens
experiment number one I I was like fine
you know Brody if that's who you want on
the show you know I'll have a little
extra stay in the bedroom you know in
hiding
to get the kitchen in the bedroom I'm so
awkward for me though like having well
I'm sure is that so up can you release
it again yeah it's it's Becca it's still
on YouTube if you just type in Brody
Stephens experiment number one what year
was that like 2040s eight years ago
maybe nine years ago will always be like
when you talk podcasts you cannot talk
podcast without death squad death squad
is the og of this used to say until I
die you always said that's a - squad
till I die dude that's all this came
from yeah and it was so popular that
Bill Simmons jacked the format of
putting all the same podcast on one feed
and he did the same thing for the
longest time
Podcast Network yeah bill Simmons is
Bill Simmons he's a horse man sport a
sports man he knows okay here it is dude
now if you scroll down or is that the
actual article but if you scroll down if
that's been my actual photo oh no that's
the actual article yeah because in the
photo below the picture she like
translates the article for it for you I
like this 2011 she was hospitalized
because this is the translation I mean
not just the archaic translation of it
player he pitched Finland I had a I was
working on the radio back in Cleveland
when Brody had his meltdown were you
guys around when that was going down
yeah yes yes did you did you visit him
in the hospital when I know a lot of
comics went to the hospital and visited
I didn't go
I was in distraught it was like I was
calling Brodie what's going on man I'm
super sad I called them a bunch of times
the other day but when I found out but
then I was confirmed I call this phone
yesterday just to hear his voice mail
there's an there way to pull those voice
that they answer she message you can put
it in a beer a bear or something like
that begging oh yeah yeah voicemails and
eyes enough doesn't have footage out
there Brodie bear you know who you just
got a hold of yeah every time you touch
the bear that's what his outgoing
messages ninety-percent bear well man we
love them we'll keep you posted on
everything that we are going to do this
is the hardest part of our core our
careers is that when we lose a friend
this show must go on
and it's really sucks yeah you like to
go up on stage the night and people have
to perform that night I don't know how
you did that man it had to be I cried at
the end I tried not to but I you know
it's fine it sucks it sucks we did our
podcast because I felt like that's what
we should have done maybe I was wrong to
inflict you guys into that but I felt I
want people to come down but I feel so
[ __ ] I mean it was 12 hours right
though that nobody wanted to on even ten
hours after we found out Jeff Ross at
the improv he was unstoppable just this
is fine and he goes we lost a good
friend Brody Stephens place gets quiet
he goes yeah he goes I hear we're gonna
bury him at the Laugh Factory where
comedy goes to die Chad Zuma burning
bridges already burning bridges it's a
Jeff Ross joke okay so where do we go
from here man no it's just we've all
been zombies since this know maybe if
people won't call it let's just make
sure that we control these calls so that
people don't
call men try to do some other [ __ ] well
I mean just be closer to hang up button
that's what's the phone number 1-800
bang mom Oh three to call pal electric
well fix it yeah if you're watching this
live you can see what the number is at
the bottom righthand four three two
three two eight two seven four two four
I want to ask you about your British
shows how was British comedy compared to
American comedy mm-hmm well that's the
Ireland especially the kill Tony like
comics the people that are only doing
one out of all the kill Tony's we've
done three hundred and plus 50 shows
whatever they were the least amount of
people to sign up like Ireland we had it
only like at one point like six people
when like we can't even do a show with
six people signing up so we had to like
really get people to sign up more like
tell them to sign them a lot of people
weren't there I don't know like London
was good but man Manchester and Ireland
that's that's some very dark depressing
comedy out there I don't think they have
like the same kind of comedy clubs as
though they say that British or your
Europe comedy is kind of where we were
in the 80s right yeah and the whole the
whole vibe of London and everything was
it felt like 40 years ago like I like
technology-wise like you know there's
like one power outlet per room like that
drove me crazy you know like all the
hotels had one power outlet you have to
reserve a spot specially without [ __ ]
an extension cord job I mean I have like
tons of equipment I need to charge up
and you know do all that [ __ ] so but no
London was really cool though we went to
like we don't know where the queen is or
whatever wherever that is the palace
thing went to do not mind she's
technically work dude she's the largest
landowner how much money that is Oliver
land is where trillions thirty three
trillion dollar yeah it's ridiculous 33
trillion dollar you ever seen the list
of people that owned like all the land
yeah was that you that pitch today okay
that's yeah yeah that's interesting
that's creating a second person was not
even close it's like I'm only worth one
trillion
I've always just wondered what um
well I mean the translation I dude the
funniest was uh was re going to the
Edinburgh Festival and just like I they
would challenge me to comedy shows that
I would just destroy them mm-hmm I would
just kill them what do you think
happened that fish by the way how dead
is that fast that fish was dead in that
picture yeah you probably drank it right
okay we got a call so that for now on on
Skype that's always gonna be that sound
no I just have it turned off okay how
high you're on with it does get our
punch-drunk we just got hung up on Bob a
baby's in danger so he [ __ ] figure
out where that baby is that baby is in
danger
what is the demo on the show drunk
babies Oh drunk baby remember the days
of having phones in your house and just
prank calling and stars and like weird
like picking up on the phone with moms
on the phone and you're just listening
to your mom and you would have no idea
who would call you like the foliage is
ringing like it was a real crapshoot
they're going to jail or I'm getting
[ __ ] but I'm just gonna roll the dice
and answer it there will never be a
jerky boys again we used to just you
dial your area code yeah exactly that's
what you would do [ __ ] yeah or then you
got smart about it and you would do the
phone book so you knew their first and
last name you know how does this guy
know both of my name
deeper than me I would just call hi
you're on with sports BAM it's just a
numbers game
there's another baby we gotta figure
this out I mean Skype sucks hi turn your
radio up please turn your radio down
hello hi you're on turn your radio down
you're on with punching sports sports
band crunching numbers it's just the
game it's just the numbers cave Brian
hey did you you guys watch any soccer
while you're over there
soccer yes yes and we watched a lot of
soccer which is interesting because for
a lot of reasons I've been yeah because
they don't it's a lot of people don't
know that they actually call soccer out
there soccer like football no no yeah
it's a lot of people think that are
confused about that no is it weird that
they're trying to get rid of foot the
foot part of football like they they're
trying to get rid of punt they're trying
to get rid of a kick off they'd like to
get rid of [ __ ] you they offended your
fault no but it's just like that's the
name of the game yeah we call a football
it's ridiculous you should be called
Smash Ball mm-hm
yeah yeah what what oh I know of a black
guy you guys could have on Ian Edwards
okay thanks man we were asking to look
like a people on the show all the time
dude hey good to see Brody dude I
actually did I saw him open for Ian how
he did a special oh oh that's right him
and Bill bolt I wonder if they film that
at all yeah I wonder if he's in the
opening again he must have well that'd
be great you could release that yeah he
was traveling around with David Spade
though too right oh yeah he was about to
go on the road with me oh that sucks
I just really yeah you're right god damn
it thanks for that up dude hang up on
God and Farley
yeah he has operant conditioning he's
got Pavlov's dogs over here here's the
Buzzard you just starts drooling for
meat powder yeah and and Farley this
guy's been doing a lot yeah no that was
a [ __ ] homie right there dude it's
like you just get through it
can we get through this well you can
make a bet on that a bet des I bet the
aside for all your Betty needs your
money I know yeah go to bed Deus I use
the promo code punch 25 let's go get $25
ah cooking about bet on sports you know
the moments passed
why do you hate fun yeah go to bed yes I
used could punch 25 and whatever you put
in up to five hundred dollars they'll
double all the better
absolutely guarantee we got Bitcoin up
there payout quick you can know you
could bet on MasterChef junior you can
bet you can bet on the way kids I wish
they were allowed to still go to work
and [ __ ] earn their they can they can
you just call them chores that's why
that's the only reason I want a kid so
bad just to do chores you know yeah you
can rent a kid to mow your lawn I'm not
allowed legally I think they just can't
be from your neighborhood now that's a
great point Jason Jason's on fire today
Jason early got that American Football
League champion shot you like that you
know seems like d-league I like it as
much as you like d-league basketball me
ask you something is football like this
is it almost when you're like with
somebody you love so much but you need a
break like do you need a break from
football or it is football something you
could watch all year long I need a break
but usually like
around like this time of the year or
like early spring
I'll catch like a Canadian football game
on ESPN or something I'm like oh I'll
watch this nothing else on you know this
is kind of keeping my interest but I
don't like have a favorite team that's
not in the NFL or not it you know I'm
not like I got to see how the Amsterdam
Admirals are doing you know what are you
doing just looking at Twitter why are
you doing that I'm just looking at it
what is this read it I know but it did
this just happen no this is old yeah
well I don't open this can of worms
maybe might be going into the penalty
box Brown maybe I like it I tried to get
me to read it here we have Sam hate you
and the fans turn against you this guy
just tried to set me in the penalty box
gets a chat you're going into the
penalty box Chad just got himself a
five-minute breather to think about what
he just did yeah do you guys I mean
there's so many goddamn good ones but a
lot of people been because I've been
listening a lot of people's podcast and
read a lot of people's suppose do you
guys have like a couple or one or two
like favorite Brody jokes of yours cuz
I've the sense thought of something I
hadn't thought of what are your favorite
that is his sister used to beat him with
keys when he was a kid and a deal and
and the reason to suck so much is
because she was a janitor yeah but he
don't one they always would get me he
talked about the hangover hangover to
cut out of funding people and then he
goes but guess what
just booked a new film and you know
let's get an applause break and he goes
it's an adult film shot in the valley
and I'm doing a solo scene on a yoga mat
yeah that's my favorite that was my
always my fear
a solo scene on a yoga mat watching
Brody watch porn is also very satisfying
did you watch Brody maybe porn many
times I'm broken yes I am I only hear
about this knob after his passing this
should be its own website so I'm Brody
and Esther you used to pull up horn and
get him - well yeah I think there's a
famous clip Brody Stephens my free cams
or something like that web cams but here
on that kick yeah but like he's just
listening to him topical yeah look yes
you know it's the funniest thing ever
watching him watch porn puncturing
sports we're remembering our good friend
Brody Stephens and the festival of love
yeah Sammy
yeah we can hear you buddy what's
happening team love you red bin love you
Sam what's happening no I love Sam he's
like the more than you martyr of comedy
now this your dad no I'm saying Sammy's
sticking up for comedians talking [ __ ] I
get you got a lobster oh dude I love you
dude this is like this is like tech
support calling you huh
control-alt-delete
control-alt-delete go on buddy sorry
about that god I feel like since Ari
doesn't give a [ __ ] about your podcast
no more there needs to be a Jewish
representation in the podcast so this is
your boy from Israel talking oh [ __ ]
love this is real suggest we make Chad
convert but I'm listening to you Chad
some guy from Israel wants to take your
spot then [ __ ] Chad oh [ __ ] hopefully
you stay out for 20 minutes Chad feel
helpless right now he feels and
suggested an extra is five minutes you
know the Jews run the media he wants to
put five more minutes on this timer by I
say not today not now
my buddy Chad
back on the show in 1 minute 57 seconds
tall are you actually calling from
Israel yeah I'm actually uh I got to I
got to see I got a sorry about the loss
of your buddy Brody I met him once when
I was in LA thank you it was such a [ __ ]
is that in the back okay that's your
that's the music of your people I don't
like that [ __ ] anymore
[Laughter]
hey dude talk to me about Israeli female
soldiers twerking is that like what
everybody's talking about over there
those are my favorite videos I mean
listen when you go to the military we
have like the three like the Holy
Trinity as soldiers is uh you know one
is a [ __ ]
commander a female preferably the second
is killing Arab sorry no no we
considered a sport to kill Arab
oh Christ dude why are people just women
are always the best legs
that's a bath you know Jewish chicks say
they go wait in hell they put guns on
the table Jewish girls are the BAP 'end
to the guys is it true that your girl is
Jewish yes she is Jewish consider we're
finished collar of the day today
watching your people dance look at this
I'm a comic from Israel just want to say
to read Ben he remembered me I did kill
Tony like three years ago I went to LA
just to do a minute on this side oh and
Tony dude I love it down by the way he's
making fun of your Jewish accent so Oh
awesome comeback all right buddy stop
stop find love with people
let's bring love to the world and I'm
sorry we're not talking anymore that cuz
I'm banging one of your [ __ ] it's
okay bye buddy take care
that was a good call that was a great
call and I like how this guy calls you
Redmond Redmond is it true your girl is
Jewish yes we are done talking now we
had a good run can we isolate that good
call that was a good call from Israel
speaking of Jews where is that other Jew
a Jew shape a minute 20 a porch a dome
where he um where we but that guy well I
mean you know live by the penalty box
type a death penalty that's so [ __ ]
truth that's so [ __ ] true where that
goes oh did you guys did anybody watch
the Oscars yeah I did
did you enjoy it I hate the Oscars I I
don't want to it's just watching people
that do speeches and thanking people you
don't know like and somebody told me
like I like how they didn't have a host
this year so it's longer speeches I
forget who wrote that on Facebook [ __ ]
you want a longer [ __ ] who said that
no it's 40 minutes shorter than it was
last year I needed to be about three
hours shorter I mean I I don't know what
I like about a compilation of who one
where it who likes this Black Panther me
or not black or whatever that movie does
no superhero no nobody like no one likes
that movie but they liked it I said well
if you're black I mean please dream on
he'd start fighting you right made a
little bit of money I tried to watch
that thing 20 minutes in it was the
cheesiest it was the worst of all the
Marvel movies he agreed with me on the
podcast the other day absolutely did not
he did he said it was a chunk it's just
like he's called it his exact words were
reverse racism I don't want to Thor the
dark world can't forget about bo3 and
gentles why
welcome back why does he hate black
people I don't know about the dead folks
are great well I mean dude I can power
rank it's not even top five
top 10 movie of the year no you know no
I hope this is that baby again go to the
phone you're on punch-drunk hello if you
have a drunk baby call in oh [ __ ] it's
the rumen are you checking involved Oh
Ruben Adi is here room annatee [ __ ] you
got any good spicy rumors that you're
making up while you take a [ __ ] yeah
I've been trying to call it for weeks
but the NFL has been blocking my number
blocking you guys I gotta crash oh [ __ ]
let's hear it dude and foil that this is
brought to you by our good friends at
caveman coffee
caveman coffee go to caveman coffee calm
use a promo code punch-drunk and you'll
get 15% off of all your purchase well
what we're gonna give you dude
they got caught can you look up caveman
coffee they got teas
they got coffee they got nitro they got
cups they got weed no they don't have
we'd chat Chad there's one rule did you
didn't know you'll [ __ ] with the
sponsors okay everybody's want me to hit
this thing okay there's nature I don't
you know they're nitro is great it's
great and dude and there's they love to
show so much they decide to sponsor our
celebrity hotline which is now got which
we have the room annatee guy on so go to
caveman coffee once again use the promo
code punch drunk and get 15% off your
purchases so talk to me room annatee
what's going on first one the following
list of NFL and NBA players like using
transvestite prostitutes ready okay give
me put Jimmy Butler yes so Westbrook
yeah yeah we all know about Dwight
Howard yeah sacred cube yes I met him on
father-to-be oh you do yeah so you know
that Baker Mayfield does not play the
NBA NFL NBA oh I thought you two sit on
it have a lit match my apologies my
training Network I still get back to me
on all of these NFL and NBA players so
are you breaking news right now is there
some breaking news
I this is breaking news the views got a
breaking new thing click it now did you
have a breaking news wait don't have
breaking news hit any of those buttons
hit any of those red bad
I got breaking we got breaking news here
we go I'm gonna keep going keep going
with the yes so we all know about we all
know about rajon rondo
yes like in that [ __ ] booty yeah if
you remember earlier in the season you
had crabs Chris Paul and what's-his-name
getting into an argument earlier yeah
yeah yeah no no Rondo and Chris Paul
Chris Paul in them Rondo it what spurred
girl wasted on them no that's Rondo dude
Rajon Rondo why did I give up
nonetheless sorry better folks I got a
gas okay go on the reason they were the
reason they were arguing and yelling
back and forth at each other was turns
out that the [ __ ] they were using to
like pass back and forth gave them both
chlamydia and they were trying to figure
out who gave who what and Wow do
breaking fake news breaking claim videos
transgender person hmm I don't think
they can give chlamydia what do you mean
course they can with a fake vagina you
fine but chlamydia alright it's like
chlamydia thank you from a vagina its
chlamydia clam baby yeah this guy's
getting its clip midian you probably got
those from the oysters that you were
[ __ ] eating any other rumors dude
yeah so and Bryce Harper we're going to
do some baseball talks for Aaron is
going to be we find with two men under
but then oh drop the call no he hung up
that's what the room Anat he does he
leads us to something he said resize so
he's inferring the Nationals but I don't
think that's true I think a lot of
people are concerned that he's going to
sign in
with the Dodgers though I don't know but
the ability to play close to home and
train in Arizona both appeal to Harper
and you know he's a Lakers fan so if
that may and his wife want to be got you
probably his wife wants to be on the
west coast so they said San Francisco
drop her you should drop Boris though
why don't we sign a short-term deal with
it you know get in there why why would
you why would you okay we got figure out
Skype thing because no dude it's like
every time it comes up I gotta hear that
that thing's him I gotta like it it's
fun all right hi you're on with
punch-drunk sports sports bands
crunching numbers hey guys I just wanted
to say I've been enjoying the podcast
and I just wanted to extend my
condolences to you all about oh that's
so nice of you one female caller thank
you our only female when was the last
time literally can I ask you how many
years have we gone since we had somebody
with a vagina Collin five five years
five years and now is Mac hard Sammi I
got a bigger dick than you so thank you
for listening did you ever see Brody
Stephens live I'm so bummed because I
live in LA but unfortunately I never got
the chance if you live in LA you
accidentally would see Brody
yeah have you ever been to a Starbucks
in the valley and you saw I'm Audrey mad
he performed everywhere do you hear him
say well he goes yeah I think Chris
D'Elia wants to hang out and Steve's
like yeah why don't you I can't
Steve's like why because he's a coffee
being guy and I'm a Starbucks guy I bet
you I won't Dez anyone checked if
Starbucks stock dropped since all that
coffee's gone
that's one dude not buying all that
coffee well I hope that you could come
to the the large fit it's not the
memorial it is a remembrance I have to
say that look at this
five days ago Brody pastor
oh look an eye drop right there dropped
on the day Brody died their stock
pummeled serious oh my god dude that's
not a coincidence either
that is not five days ago
yeah oh my god if you google Brody
Stephens in Starbucks its twitter
twitter it's a non-stop non-stop tweets
well young lady we appreciate you
calling in and sharing your condolences
and hopefully we could see you at the
Comedy Store when any of us get hashtag
we know we need you to get our back girl
you know it's coming yeah we get hit
with a me to these broads with their
husbands was the H word I take gender
defense to that she should say my other
person that I'm with yes a guy did you
guys ever see when Brody was documenting
that dice guy at Starbucks the guy was
rolling dice I was crazy
he loved interesting people an eccentric
guy yeah in a good way you know to me
and he was an exposure i Scott Brody
Brody and he has gravitated towards you
know he loved like you know a Kevin Lee
lied boom Shakalaka
the dice guy like people that are like
off that a lot of people would be like
oh I don't to be around that person he
wrote only one of the most loving races
I've ever met he sometimes he was
definitely more racist than other time
so you know like he definitely
definitely definitely thought Trump was
doing a good job I'll say that it looks
like he's calling it right now Brody are
you with us
Brody Brody Brody you're frozen Oh
Rodie in his cricket nice guy after dark
hahaha guys guy
[Laughter]
well if you missed any days on Brody's
life for the last five years they're all
documented on periscope in 12-hour
intervals yeah really
that's one good thing about the internet
now it's like you won't really miss
people
Brody's on the phone Brody's asyou yeah
I love I ate your Brody if Brody and
Yakov Smirnoff hello it's a pie yeah is
that all we got from you I think he's
tapped out I'm trying a little bit more
but I'm just drinking some apple cider
vinegar and I'm trying to make sure that
I'm a good guy does that give rich
little never knew Brody but just tried
to do his impression give a deal one two
arms crossed negative I'm sorry I'm
sorry look at the picture big shirts oh
that's cool yeah
the shirts that he's going to make
Brandon chops make him for the are
they're gonna sell them no they're gonna
give them to the staff in comics it's
great I want one no I said comics oh
here we go
and then these are the posters we're
gonna make that's great I do a positive
energy take one I hate have fun I'm a
good guy blue-collar Jewish we're gonna
give that a mess we're gonna sell those
hi you're out with punch-drunk just
Brody sue well no it's not dude this is
Ahri's redneck cousin no this isn't who
is this how are you hey Frank
how are you
let's be frank let's be frank Frank did
you ever get to see Brody no that says
did you just jizz right there do a bong
rip hang on let me put you on speaker
Franklin are you nervous to speak to Sam
triply what why would we pick up dude
this is love Brody Steven always say
that it's always so fun of me like you
call everybody oh [ __ ] you answered you
called
yeah when back in Seattle go look it up
Brody public-access look up Brody
public-access for the days Adam Ray said
he was a fan of that when he was a kid
like he would watch it yeah he was in
seeing so he was really big it's
actually for the area it was really big
yeah check this out yeah what year does
that say that is by the way just out of
curiosity 20 years ago it's gotta be
look at that font oh yeah this is
paintbrush the other guy is his buddy I
believe yeah yeah who had a big dick and
decided to do poor yeah look at Brody
looks so Terra see what Y is
that's the 10% wow this is just terrible
audio it's buzzing it's buzzing it's
like straight from a VHS I mean even
just even not just that has a big dick
so he decided to just go in the porn
he went in the porn yeah he's just as
banging chicks that's where he got AIDS
oh my gosh
man public-access is just the best right
Wow
we should definitely wish our good buddy
Micky Gaal good luck this weekend
oh is he fighting this weekend yeah he's
on that big Johnny Jones he's on that
Jon Jones car you pull up that with that
Jon Jones fight card Jones [ __ ] uh
who else is there's another great fight
on it I type in Brody Stephens cream pie
that's it's another video that a lot of
people have never seen I mean without
question Jon Jones wins this fight yes
it's coming out it's dripping out my
eyes I think that's I think you just
ordered the fight
oh gosh you know what that's fine just
does anybody follow dice on Instagram
yeah his videos with Eleanor are classic
it's ridiculous they have such a funny
back-and-forth
tyron woodley Guzman badass wins return
with us fo and they're getting out
giving him a tomato can't either Robbie
Lawler who Rob you'll always been sad
his face touched a bunch and in the last
while John John but he still Robbie law
was no joke John Jones is on it two
title shots so they're letting John
Jones still fight this is his big return
you're on punch drop all clean how's it
going fight for this how's it going man
not too bad what are you guys up to
talking about Brody yeah talking a
little UFC talking a little Brody yeah
he's a good guy it's too bad I'm
grateful that he was here the time that
he was yeah do you ever get to see Brody
my condolences go out to huh did you
ever get to see Brody life
no I didn't I wanted to because his
boomer was right at my own just you
depressing world and yeah life's no fun
it kind of sucks well you know you
should watch is live from the main room
special produced by comedy dynamics I
know they get the proceeds but still
it's a good rappers and
oh yeah what Brody would do at the
comments or that's exactly it I just
watched that actually yesterday because
I really I've only known about him a
little bit but that one kind of summed
it all up and it just yeah it uh
captures his life in my special needs I
don't know I mean to me it was like he
was a great comment he just it was too
much depression man too much seriousness
you know I mean I try not to be serious
myself but it's like you know yeah yeah
yeah he always had that uh that's the
thing that bugged me the most though
with all the mental illness things is
like in the past you could tell when he
was having really bad yes yeah we had so
many warning signs before and this one
we this one yeah recently such a great
mood it seemed like I'm on Wednesday and
Thursday comparable II to like yeah so
that's though I think that's the thing
that bugs a lot of us is that you know
there was no red flags really this time
it was just kind of out of nowhere we
had weeks and weeks of actually we had
the opposite of red house he's talking
about going on tour I supposed to go be
with the Cubs a week later
yeah it's about yeah go about to go on
the road he's a bit started going on the
road with you know and that's that was
new to him and being on the road yeah
it's the same with Anthony Bourdain and
the saying like I've had you know this
personal friends tell themselves this
year and it's like you know there's no
worrying sign you know the person is
kind of depressed and [ __ ] but then it's
like [ __ ] you just blew his brains out
or also until hung themselves and yeah I
think the world's coming to an
idealistic point where everyone's in
Iowa's there's no more meaning you know
whether you're really nice or not
doesn't land a sister there's hardly a
meaning a mark and the web saturated
with [ __ ] you know and I trying to be
the best honest but it's like I just I
could see beyond bugs and and people
like that people are the same kind of
just level of like yeah well the world
is kind of losing its meaning because
there's so much fake [ __ ] punk down
I throw it's 24/7 and then we got to
kind of make up our minds what's real
what's not and then I just kind of lose
a value this is you know second angle
really
that's the one thing about Brody he saw
through all that stuff he would we would
had long talks about like just all the
phone enos and fakeness it really
bothered him I remember that oh yeah
it's irritable it's really I think you
want to do something about it but then
you don't know exactly what the [ __ ] to
do about it like well how do I make
people not realize you know help them
realize it's not that serious I'm not
like should be gone and if you live in
the moment have a good time they kill
live with your loved ones and blah blah
blah but how the [ __ ] you do that and
that is what makes you want to keep
going more thank you you know like you
said he's got all these specials coming
off the planet that two aren't planning
this it's still you never knoe with
anybody so it's kind of just living the
moment enjoying why you got them and
just understand it could be any time
[ __ ] the time with any [ __ ] buddy no
matter what yeah I'll never take Tebow
for granted not very good well thanks
for calling bruh I appreciate your kind
words for Brody and MN familiarize this
material look him up on YouTube you know
you won't miss you're missing out and
missing out if you haven't a lot birdie
to make you laugh and you know luckily
for all of us all that stuff will be out
there forever and you know anytime you
miss him you can always go back and have
a good laugh because he was great at
that back to the UFC I'm excited for
this card I believe Mickey Gaul is on
the undercard and it's actually a good
fight as far as a Geryon nightmare
that's a nickname that says yeah no joke
you know he's 30 and 11 this guy's got
41 fights Jaeger Sanchez but my man make
you guys 5 him on if I went to bet TS I
use the code punch 25 I throw all 25
actually I throw another 75 in there not
throw all hundred of it Mickey gall
no photos on this website guys with
Mickey gall cause he's so gorgeous oh
it's only the UFC's website Mickey gone
makes me 10% K and I dedicate that to
Brody Stephens you're on punch-drunk
hello yo what do you type it on a
typewriter what's going on over there
you Eleanor its dad's house yo what's up
you called us what's the word bird wait
this is a bird yeah I think so like AZ
said bird sounds like he was pecking
into a tree that's a pretty good call
yeah very called 'hey guys guys if
you're going in think about what you
might say yo you're on the air what's up
hey how are you brother
wow this is woody what you got bro you
know yo you guys are watching those
Brody Stevens videos one that I saw
yesterday that I think it's due to Adam
hunter sure Adam it's a black barbershop
barber
yeah and he's doing stand-up in the
barber probably watch go on yeah thanks
brother you open for Spade I did thanks
thanks thanks you know one funny thing
about Brody is how he always was very
subconscious about his scar on his face
laser I never could see you never can
stand he was just like when that
happened he was inside he was so mad he
was talking about suing everybody I'm a
I make a living with my face and you've
damaged it yes I remember when he
remember when Prodi broke his arm 20
people in this black barbershop I just
recently found out that my grandfather
has Down syndrome
[Laughter]
to attend the crips I was in the coldest
right I pulled her hair I said you
listen to me you listen to me I'll take
you to Manuel I'm very intense I get B
in the shower
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's hilarious I've never seen that
I've never seen idea really funny yeah
that takes balls I first I met Brody
before I moved out here
when Joe was on the man show no news
doing what he was doing audience warm-up
so I visited LA before I moved out here
and he was the warm-up guy and I went to
a couple tapings and I remember I was
like first time ever at a TV show but I
was so like who's this guy screaming at
us you know like I didn't I think a lot
of it no that was a job right right I
did I didn't I think a lot of people
when they first see Brody they don't get
it you know they're like who's this guy
screaming you know and and I just
remember when I move
California we went to the comedy store
the first day to move and I go oh my god
there's the guy that yelled at us so
much you know like I saw Brody and I was
almost scared of that guy it was like he
yelled has made us clap for two hours
and and it's weird I think a lot of
people you have to grow into Brody and
like not many times see Brody alright
you see Brody or your first time and go
wow that was you know awesome you know
yeah yeah yeah you came from Columbus
right yeah okay yeah that was at 2000
what year it's been about 13 years now
14 years some way that 13 seems longer
than the maybe I maybe it's longer my
first year doing comedy was 2005 I
started here and I remember I was on a
show with Brody and he watched me and
afterwards I went up to him and I didn't
do well I was like hey Brody it's nice
to meet you I'm a big fan and he's like
what's your name
I go Chad he's like keep writing keep
getting onstage and the very next day he
sent me on myspace friend request he
remembered my name
that's exactly how was he wasn't quite
he was he was the opposite of Sam Triple
E with people's names he what you would
say his name once he would remember it
forever like in a shocking way like
Sam's a phony like he'll like pretend
like you know it's not even that it's
just he just when it comes to that oh
gosh I was getting to go on like 90% of
Sam's all-time best friends in his phone
are a guaranteed misspelled in his phone
because he's had their numbers centi
phonetically tried to just spell your
name yeah like Joe Rogan I guarantee you
Tiana sericia honey you know yeah I'm on
oh [ __ ]
what's up oh [ __ ] hey I want to talk
about this man go right ahead and all
why not my sellout start doing it why
not let's start talking Brody all right
so the same time Brody was going through
his [ __ ] I was going through my [ __ ] I
think all the mental health issues were
going through his environmental grows
without personal [ __ ] people are going
through and people don't want to tell us
that [ __ ] [ __ ] is polluted
[ __ ] is [ __ ] people for all we know
could be using the infrastructure that
we have like [ __ ] radars and [ __ ] on
Mount Wilson to [ __ ] launch attacks
against
California so nobody's [ __ ] talking
about this [ __ ] everybody getting sick
all day at the same time [ __ ] fires
that [ __ ] never happened 30 years I
[ __ ] you thought this tinfoil hat
this is punch-drunk sport thank you
they're bleeding into your other shows
man yeah welcome to tinfoil punch-drunk
let's get naughty show mr. mr. radars
man in the fires fires never existed
before now they do the thing about Brody
Stevens was that Brody wanted to have a
Chris D'Elia career but Brody never
realized he had a Brody Stephens career
and it was like I used to tell him all
the time man
dude you are the most loved dude I know
I when we went on tour no matter how
hard I crushed on our tour and I crushed
hard I mean I think we'd all agree that
I had some pretty legendary I worried
you weren't gonna be able to spin this
into how great you are no matter how
well I did but it was always Brody
Stevie Wonder oh you remember we did the
Texas tour yeah when I crushed I don't
remember that part that hard but I
remember the last show was in Austin I
think we're at cap city and that week
the staff was tired I guess they had
sold-out shows at Doug Benson and they
just wanted to go home it was a Sunday
show and Brody went on last and the
staff was just no and then all of a
sudden the staff was laughing like he
reenergized them like they went from
Waco all of my set they would go think I
remember they loved Florentine set and
my said no yours is weird and but
Brody's they really really liked
I remember going on the road with him
and Chad wanted to close some shows but
we're like Chad how long have you been
doing he's like 10 years and I'm like
okay Brody's been doing it it's 2005 30
how long had Jim been doing it like 28
and I've been doing it 24 yeah so you
were the babe I was 22 at that moment so
you were the baby and you had to open
yeah well Brody did great Jim did great
I did great it was it was fun
just one time I gave you a chance I
showed you okay and you ran it ran it
yeah
boom um joke's on us though Chad's
getting all the donuts yeah Chad its
penalty box
now go do something else for five
minutes oh yeah Chad by the way just got
pause because it's penalty box not like
I don't know time was that donut time
would sound so good but this guy's just
sucking him down the only time was great
you got a donut and some hot [ __ ] ass
Oh 10% gay for Brody okay
ah hey you're on with a punch-drunk are
you there that's me yeah five a five for
life oh man I cannot believe what
happened to Brody I'm I'm a big fan I
thought through
I had a psychotic break and got section
like him and was a big like took
inspiration from him and I was and like
I went crazy and I could never I don't
think braid Brody ever went crazy like I
did like I could never figure out why he
was sectioned and like um but maybe it
was because he was suicidal or anyways
but I think I'm a big fan he came to
Vermont like I know he's mostly in
Southern California and he came to
Vermont I went to see him after I got
out of the hospital and like met him and
I got his autograph and talked to him
and told them I'm always on periscope
and there's like a lot of people on
periscope that would talk to Brody and
and he would say is it you know is it
normal to feel weird adjusting your meds
and we'd say we love you you know either
either way we we love you no matter what
honor off drugs
and and he's always you know um he was
like I want to mention some of these
people like Monica was a big thing
Linette Linette okay she latina her Ana
latina turncoat Casey bill JC okay okay
we get there's a lot of people I this is
like roll calls right now I guess I'm
sorry I dude it's so played a lot of
people call them we want to make sure we
get everybody in all right
my name is Darcy and I love Brody and
I'm like I'm off meds and I was like you
know I never thought like I didn't think
he needed meds but it's like really
scary for me now because you know I look
for him I looked to him for inspiration
anyway sorry to ramble I look that's
alright Brody and Esther and you have
friends that you have that they have
your number so if you're off these mute
all and check in on you cuz that's the
biggest thing we got to do with these
things because our friends are getting
on and off these medication these
medications are made by voodoo people
who are just all about a dollar and they
put in there so you get [ __ ] hooked
on that [ __ ] so when you get off it it
[ __ ] with your skull when you get on it
it [ __ ] what you should all so you have
to have about four nine numbers of
people who have your number that you
have to answer the phone when they call
or and they're allowed to come check up
on you to make sure you're okay okay
do you have an Allen I've got that but
you know what also like you say tell
someone if you feel suicidal but like I
was on suicide watch
and they'd [ __ ] feel like it's it's
almost worse to be on suicide watch
because still like they they'll watch
you go to the bathroom and they're like
all in your face it's like
like you you're almost after you go
through that once and maybe this is what
happened to Brody you're scared to say
oh I'm suicidal because they protocol is
fun I get that yeah anyway it's Tripoli
you're the man and just keep all this
[ __ ] I mean who knows and also
there's such there's like different
opinions like especially like pot in
psychosis I have to mention that kind of
cuz like I was a Humboldt State
University and smoke pot my whole lives
and like I don't know maybe there's
something like maybe it can cause I cuz
you know tell you something and people I
know smoke a lot of weed I sensors
sometimes some bipolar ness they they're
[ __ ] cool one second and he cut on
your necks that's just life but I
appreciate you calling in you can call
into us anytime you need help okay are
you feeling down calling to us we'd love
to talk to you alright sorry that you
said you feel that way about chat take
care of man man what were they saying
that was like one of those when he
started giving shoutouts to everybody
that ever was a fan of Bodhi was like
what you we used to almost need to play
him off like the academy or what about
some Robert crap thoughts if you want to
lighten the load yeah well it's not just
Robert crap the CEO of C Citigroup the
bank got busted good I'm sure he did all
the bankers are crooked this is the guy
that said he never cheats now you got
cheating from the top down from your
goddamn girlfriend and your wife all the
way to your [ __ ] organization so much
cheating we don't cheat man pages don't
cheat yeah
ask your goddamn girlfriend [ __ ] so
what do you do he's got a hand job and
we got caught trying to pay for a
[ __ ] that's fine a [ __ ] okay Mike
I drew hope because you're an idiot if
you I would trust him so much I would
trust an NFL owner so much less if
you're actually paying for a [ __ ] the
only thing that you can do better than
them
that's what means he just frivolous with
money $100 that's it this guy's a
millionaire oh it's supposed to be 40
bucks so you know heat is good you know
forty bucks for a thousand dollars the
going price at these places so yeah he
did you tip over double what he was
supposed to yeah I think it's good I
think prostitution should be legal know
what bugs me is that cops can go in
there and quit with cameras and [ __ ]
without even the massage parlor knowing
about it that freaks me out
yes a you know I always thought you know
like if the place gets raided you just
like put on your pant you know boxer
just put a towel over you you know talk
about how safer Florida is now that
these chicks aren't giving hand jobs to
billionaires I love the irony that he
got illegally secretly taped fire today
but if this isn't entrapment think about
this at 11:02 they in the morning the
cop of course this guy's old as [ __ ]
it's just hate those [ __ ] pills you
don't know when they pop so quick he's
just getting a quick mouth town some
point you got boner you're 80 you're
like something's got jerk this thing so
the so the undercover cop begins
manipulating craft penis and testicles
then put her head down by his penis if
that in entrapment I don't know what is
yeah that's the massage parlor girl oh
then she's just trying to [ __ ] get
just trying to make trying to get to her
lunch break
she's 15 minutes away from her lunch
break she ain't gonna be [ __ ] around
12:02 it's a [ __ ] she gave him a hug
after she gave him a hug yeah she got
him she helped him get dressed and gave
him a hug that was nice oh and he did
service he did give more because it says
crafting gave her $100 bill plus another
run detect unidentifiable bill out just
to just say they they didn't use a
condom which is very rare for massage
parlor because this is they they he
wiped up his cream afterwards well hey
let's let's also give some credit to
this [ __ ] old man here he walks in
this room at 10:59 at 11:13 she's
already paid and he's out the door hey
blue
at 14 minutes yeah that actually credit
goes to this woman so congrats to you
lady Bob Kraft has [ __ ] going on not all
heroes wear capes I mean that's that's
14 minutes of getting undressed getting
hard getting a massage on your balls
getting your dick sock getting a towel
wrapped around you two hugs a payment
with a generous tip and you're gone time
is money you know how long it takes him
to take his cufflinks off I mean jeez
oh I'm sure this guy walked in in a
[ __ ] nine piece suit that's
impressive
this guy likes to spray Robert Kraft I
might take back everything I'm saying
this is why massage parlors have 30
minutes sessions and hour sessions well
this guy overpaid for a 15 minute ocean
yeah he left early on a 15 minute
session this is just icing on the cake
for her mm-hmm
plus a serious korie's belly cements on
the scene so then they just cook they
just get him on his way out is that what
happened uh-huh okay yeah but sometimes
you don't want it in your house do you
just want to you know go take a 13
minute drive yeah you want to take a
spin yeah yeah yeah you want to take the
[ __ ] goddamn space shuttle out for a
quick getaway block mm-hmm honey I'm
taking the space shuttle give a dicksuck
be back in eight minutes yeah but he has
like a hot girlfriend member he got
busted with her he was running lines
with her for an acting audition
did he may recall that that was
wonderful because it's like some dumb
like Showtime B movies and you know she
has her sugar daddy yeah see that see
yeah that's his girlfriend
oh that looks like his daughter exactly
but she wants to be an actress so
there's some film that got out I don't
know how she basically recording her
audition and Robert Kraft is reading the
minor broke up I wonder if they broke up
after this that's it let's give this a
minute because this is Robert Kraft in
front of a green screen
yeah let's wait on it and then it got
then it got leaked by somebody that's
just you know they're like I got it I
got a somehow release this thing because
it's great I mean if you can imagine
Robert Kraft acting which you can't and
it's just as bad as you think
do you see what a thespian slash lesbian
this
Kimmel talking about it that's his
girlfriend right yeah that was all of
Ricki she's auditioning for a role in
the upcoming on Wilson Vince Vaughn
movie called the internship and she
needed someone to help or read lines and
that's someone to help was billionaire
well no offense but I get guys like you
and my classes all the time it's just
terrible like anyway
he's destroying her chance at getting
this audition but it's like I live in
front of a green screen is another great
question for a movie like that they just
be so funny you know why they're in a
green screen for people on the internet
to [ __ ] with them how many videos are
that with Dinosaurs in a bank that has
to be Oh cost us all over it
of course Tosh did one he's so funny
[Music]
where's Tosh bad I know Tiana just did a
show with him in Vegas the store maybe
once twice a year okay
yeah he's really rarely there
I like how he got married and it broke
like a year later like on TMZ and
everything
who did Boston yeah touched Taj got
married secretly and then they broke it
like a year later on TMZ to a girl or a
guy girl girl yeah it's a good question
though yeah what's his girl look like
pull-up Tasha's wife I don't know I
don't know what you that's well the he's
doing a parity of crafts girlfriend
right now how did he make his money
oh it's alright no crap Chuck Johnny
pull up Tasha's wife I want to see what
she looks like
I mean I'm sure she's not all right
white or black what do you guys think oh
why I'm going white I mean black
wouldn't surprise me but or pull up Bob
craft latina maybe he made all his money
on macaroni and cheese she's made a lot
of money in real estate cuz what you
make money you make money in real estate
well I'm saying how he originally got
became the B word craft isn't doing good
accompany the cheese cheese company yeah
no one's buying mac and cheese anymore
why and they're cutting corners so that
ketchup ain't as good as the other
ketchups did you see that Nike stocks
down 1.1 billion dollars that's
embarrassing since I am that is the most
when that shoe blew up Jesus Christ I
mean and and you know how much the NBA
is rock-hard Virge I on to get into the
league they're even talking about moving
to draft age to 18 and I just has none
into a Zion I'm like my dick it doesn't
cuz you'd already be making you're
already looking at how much money you be
making
this year if Zion was in the NBA and
you're like how can we fix this in case
it comes around again well the biggest
thing is that they they're trying to
figure out a way to judge the final way
to see who's ready for the leak is not
every kid who can play in the league
he's ready for the leak of course
there'll be rules and kind of things you
have to be able to go do to do it by the
way he was wearing Paul George's shoes
which apparently I was apparently that
style of shoe is one of the most common
worn by players yeah whatever that era
what they realized was actually so big
like think about the guy's his weight
they don't make those cuts no and that
shoe just was like so the guy that
happened to and the person made the shoe
made no money in this game and the
people the [ __ ] everybody thinks Coach
K's a good guy just know he's just much
of a scumbag as everybody else who makes
money off these [ __ ] kids okay coach
Kaizen any better
Zion Williams got busted asking other
colleges for [ __ ] cash but some I
goes to Coach K where he's gonna sit for
six months here's the Triple E we know
right he's gonna sit there for six
months and he's gonna [ __ ] do it for
the love of being part of a Duke no dad
they just like John Wooden a UCLA
totally [ __ ] pay for players he just
didn't want you know anything about wait
let's cut out the middleman what school
doesn't do it right
maybe this notion that Coach K and Nick
Saban are [ __ ] running these cleaning
program when they constantly get busted
and nothing happens to them but these
other schools get [ __ ] pound what's
going on in Arizona is no different than
what's going on at Duke but why is there
zona getting [ __ ] pounded on or even
where there's concrete evidence no
there's curry avenue did they just kill
it they just kill it because they these
televisions need these [ __ ] brands so
it crate says on unlevel playing field
Sam what did you think of Jerry Sandusky
is the defensive coordinator uh he's
great yeah I mean he really knew how the
[ __ ] and shut it down
receivers he was my favorite Catholic
priest yeah so that's where no I think
all came
them [ __ ] Duke what kind of oh by the
way rick pitino might be uh you know v's
new coach
bo he [ __ ] children rick pitino uh-huh
no he does yes he does they bury it
Jason sometimes you hit sometimes you
don't but going back to Zion he's
wearing Paul George's shoes and Paul
George had one of the nastiest injuries
in the history of the NBA it's just the
irony of that it's so so weird I love
this guy
so Bernie so you think Paul I mean Nikes
gonna have to ante up and pay big money
for Zion now like the recovery to come
back I mean they're gonna come a
lifetime contract don't you think or
this adidas come in there or does
British Knights make a deal okay do you
by the way as the first one we wear B
Ches at my high school and everybody
went crazy so I was a taste creator
right yeah so then when budded and other
pair sneakers nobody's ever heard of and
they just [ __ ] on me
look at those dumb [ __ ] sneakers I'm
like okay anybody else
what yeah totally on board
sabotage died on shoe why no no I would
drop it on it
what why why would they do that drop it
on it
that's awful what if he's something
about sorry stock stock plummet no
they're not gonna try keeping school
they want to the NBA they can't make
money off of Gentiles I mean I could go
with you they sabotage it because they
want to get rid of the one and done and
get these kids right - yeah okay that's
not what you were talking about that
also makes no sense either which way of
those scenarios they're only hurting
themselves out of money am I the only
one concerned about his education see if
they heard a rumor that he was about to
sign with adidas in five months I could
see that if they heard a rumor he's
about to sign with adidas in five months
to try to blow his knee out but they're
only hurting themselves out of hundreds
of millions about actually hundreds of
millions of dollars because who's he
gonna sign I mean 100% he's gonna sign
with Nike until now and even now I could
see why Nike would really wanna
him with this big makeup campaign or
something oh dude he he just you could
throw another probably 200 mil on that
deal of Nike does it that's amore so we
want something for we feel bad there's
another 200 and then Skechers just jumps
in ha ha ha
what if he goes a flip-flop well if he
goes the big baller brand he should go
at flip-flop rocks props let me ask you
do you think Zion so big he could make
big baller a real thing no I mean would
they think the love of Zion people
conspired I think the love of Zion is
less than the hatred of the ball family
especially the father thoughts sports
fan oh I didn't hear the question so the
numbers saying about Zion but as I ins
love versus the ball family hate well
let's just you know we got to go back in
history like look at look at look at
Thomas Jefferson good example a slave
owner slave owner he he watched his land
and overlooked his land and the people
that worked for him at the time you know
it was like a draft to them you know and
they would love to have shoes you know
they they used to have to just you know
work with no shoes on are you trying to
say that Zion is the Senate at Thomas
Jefferson slave yeah who's Thomas
Jefferson the NBA or college basketball
or Nike Nike is a slave owner yeah no I
mean he's not playing Nike wants to pay
him Duke doesn't college basketball
might be the slave Oh Jason Tebow
crystal clear that was our crystal clear
moment of the day I just made up a
segment get your um can we get a LeBron
James and how much he sucks and how much
I'm enjoying this hey hey LeBron don't
bring that Cleveland [ __ ] to
Tinseltown okay you that might work in
the fat
bottom girl land okay rock and roll came
from I'm fat white chicks
all right but not in Tinseltown don't
pull that [ __ ] you think you're a
[ __ ] shark
it might work in your little pond you
call it Cleveland up where the [ __ ]
Momo's run okay I've never met a guy
from Cleveland it wasn't a Momo
hey the guy shouldn't cross from one
what dude yeah that's called stuffing
that's called stuffing your stats why
the rest your team [ __ ] wilts on the
vine do the Lakers make the playoffs am
triplet go oh no no they hate him by the
way
they're not gonna dude it's actually
probably for them like [ __ ] this guy
wires
why aren't they giving coverage to the
Milwaukee Bucks right now they are he's
in the lead now for MVP well they will
all during playoffs but it's you know
who gives a [ __ ] about them they're good
don't make noise but are they great I
think LeBron is just damaging the Lakers
you know chemistry I I think it's yeah I
think he's just jump in there and
ruining everything
yeah I agree dude where think about
LeBron McNulty on the line hi Nick Nolte
which thoughts on LeBron James
hey dude this jab stop stop
how many characters do you play that you
couldn't remember what character now do
you call them multiple shows as
different characters and now you just
call or you thought you were Lance but
now is this a paid caller no this is not
a paid caller Chad it's cousin Jeff good
this is cousin Jeb Sarris cousin Sarris
cousins redneck cousin who jerks off to
his redneck cousins so to meet your
characters straight when you call in to
our show docked this is a very sad day
so we don't have time for fuck-ups I
know I was gonna tell y'all my
condolences but I got a little carried
away cause I was gonna tell you about
this hula hooper too goddamn restaurant
boys okay kohanga okay before we get
into this did you just say you had to
talk about a who
Hooper at a goddamn restaurant now is it
possible that this restaurant is not
cracker Belle is it possible this
restaurant is not a restaurant at all
but either a schoolyard or a strip club
its Hooters guys he's talking about
hitter so you know who Lupe's became
popular in 1958 whoa fun fact by sports
ban sports banned fun facts so wait yeah
wait how can we just skip over the hula
I'm looking after Ryan red band right
now what hey Chad Chad Burt are we doing
a [ __ ] show right now stop the show
to look at a periscope sit down I'm just
trying to run a professional show here
get it came to our front dying and
you're telling me about periscopes cuz
you're done please yeah sorry about that
Chad doesn't realize the power of your
calls how bad did you hear guys it's
Michael smell like a little Christmas
party for that [ __ ] restaurant I don't
even know how to goddamn things still
running but this [ __ ] comes in with a
little Princess Leia bonds or whatever
on her head sure she's carrying that
husband I was like what the [ __ ] is this
[ __ ] carrying that forward boy that
[ __ ] got some goddamn obliques like
Brad Pitt - she got that [ __ ]
hover about two inches on the ground and
bring it right back up Wow
so so the big mystery was what is she
doing with that hula-hoop the answer was
looping now how old was she obviously 18
right gasps see how this is gonna unfold
man sky's the limit
[ __ ] is prom great I think she's maybe
21 22 I can enjoy this conversation yeah
cheap serve alcohol but her boyfriend
just cheated on her with her best friend
so I think its price and you I mean I
don't have to tell y'all but it's been
I'm overdue for some [ __ ] I guess you
could say you really are what really are
what's your best friend a sword
swallower she wouldn't need to swallow a
sword if she could just swallow about
half the cucumber she'd be good with me
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
the bush y'all gonna be up in New York
is summer for skating Claire yeah I
believe all of us will be there oh yeah
I got reply to that you know well guess
what I'm gonna be there too and guess
what else this is the highest
concentration of prostitutes in Brooklyn
cuz I'm gonna get me some [ __ ] up there
I'll be goddamned
yeah I have a feeling we won't be seeing
you at any of those shows Brooklyn
prostitutes never had that thank you
judge thanks for calling we appreciate
your kind words about Brody to even say
anything about are you watching the
fudge yeah you did yeah we're watching
the fights let's watch them together
holding hands okay with it I'll be down
why is Chad walking in the penalty box
he's just got that anger anxiety bro
the penalty box gives them anxiety even
though it only smells like him over yeah
Chad don't make him reset it dude please
sit down in the penalty box these are
the rules dude this has been [ __ ]
rough it's rough it's rough
Chad in the penalty box shall we do that
guys yeah but he has to start the next
show at two minutes and 28 seconds in
I'm down all right man this has been a
really rough one Brian it's always a
pleasure to have you on please come back
and have a better shirt better chances
Johnny [ __ ] you over there and no no
you're in the penalty box bro you're in
the penalty box Chad you know what
you're getting better you only did three
times this time you're doing so much
better
ah guys it's been a pleasure we will
talk soon and thank you guys support to
show support our sponsors please donate
you Brodie's thing too if you donate to
it where Sonny just gonna go to yeah and
if you mother cover all the cost right
now they bastard goes to a mental health
the family has expressed they want that
to happen there it's a long story and
I've shown the fifth type in Christy
Stevens cream pie and that's birdies
poor name stop stop okay you just put it
in while Christie Stephens cream pie but
why I know Christie Stephens you know
Christine yeah you know that's Brody's
ex-fiance
shut up they were married or ex-wife no
she she took his name you're just
talking out your ass guys it's been a
pleasure I love you guys that's what you
get from this boy that's what you get
guys take care we'll talk to you guys
soon love you Brody that's how I take